alerte à malibu on n'oublie jamais celle
qui nous fait la baiser
[Musique]
mais celui qui nous fait re dois mon
instinct me dit qu'il se passe un truc
grave là bas et mes coups ne me dise
d'aller voir
très mauvaise idée et mitch on est
maître nageur nous moi mes couilles
elles disent si on la joue et relax moi
mes couilles elles disent ferme ta
gueule et allons voir ce qu'il magri
coup ils me font chier
cb web fonctionne c'est que nous
respectons les consignes cette pétition
c'est une cata ce mec
je suis matt brody et j'ai l'air d'en
avoir quelque chose à [ __ ] c'est un
des nageurs les plus doués du monde
c'est comme si un humain avait baisé
avec un jet ski
ce qui est impossible bien sûr mais ce
serait trop cool
c'est henri interdite se branler dont
naîtra et n'oublie pas j'ai des yeux
partout et on apprenait lui des bonnes
manières et musées vous mais ça passe à
l'heure du tout aux [ __ ]
aulas
vu les circonstances les choses auraient
pu être graves pire à peine à masquer sa
porte bonheur
pour fouiller la morgue pour trouver des
preuves
voici à des traces de piqûres sur le net
je me demande de faire quoi je lève ces
bourses et vérifie hockey son périnée
regard de mieux ça y est je vois un trou
annoncées sont trop de balles 7 6
je vais le poster que soit interdite
parce qu'il sait jamais quand même plein
de bolbec watch alerte à malibu vous
avez des cônes et le port de plaisance
et pas les x games et du sauvetage en
mode interpellation ok autant pour moi à
part que c'est du foutage de gueule de
sauvetage en mode interpellation au
cinéma le 21 juin